did we wake up at the same I've been up
since four
[Music]
it's where real writers live and I am
starting to think that I am a real
writer why didn't you tell me do not say
it say it careful now keep it to
yourself Linds
ay I just have all these voices in my
head all the time now you've done it
nice pants thanks
they're new I mean they're not new I
wear them a lot sounds like they have a
very rich history
I know exactly what you're gonna say I
wasn't gonna say anything just enjoying
the view you don't need her mama's here
okay that's creepy
[Music]
that's when you can really trust someone
to understand what you are all about
[Music]
I came here to focus on myself this
could be a life-changing opportunity you
have no reason to believe that what
about this reason
it's funny the devil's actually a very
misunderstood card
did you always want to be a writer I
think I always knew I had something to
say but just afraid no one wanted to
hear it he doesn't like you he just
thinks you're rich hey don't listen to
her you're doing great buddy what are
you thinking about nothing I've listened
to so many different people telling me
who I should be what are you doing it's
different with Lindsay because she's
special that is actually very sweet it's
time to give up and come home I belong
in the city you've been hit by three
cabs at very low speeds
all those voices floating in her head
saying no in a million different ways
they don't see what I do
she doesn't appreciate you she doesn't
deserve you this isn't your life this is
my life I am sick and tired of everyone
telling me what I'm supposed to do
[Music]
you're gonna be okay I can handle it
foreign
[Music]